you may have loved Big Bang Theory but
have you ever considered what the little
Bang Theory might look like AI is
capable of some truly alarming things
but don't worry this one is nothing but
cute we're looking at the cast of The
Big Bang Theory if these brainiacs were
babies Sheldon Cooper portrayed by Jim
Parsons is one of everyone's favorite
Big Bang Theory characters Sheldon is
truly a one-of-a-kind character and for
those of us who love him it's no
surprise that folks love to imagine what
he was like as a child after all we know
he was quite The Prodigy and
overachiever in his youth I remember
when I too was deciding my academic
future as a lowly graduate student of
course I was 14 and had already achieved
more than most of you could ever hope to
despite my 9:00 bedtime people wondered
about young Sheldon so much in fact that
an entire TV series was based around it
that series of course is Young Sheldon
you understand that some people are
going to be intimidated by you cuz of
how smart you are or maybe they'll
recognize my intellect and make me their
lead Lord look after my son don't let
him get stuffed in a gy bag it seems
that folks love young Sheldon just as
much as they love older Sheldon the
series has a seventh season in the works
when the series began in season 1
Sheldon was only 9 years old with the
help of AI however we can see him even
younger going back even earlier than
young Sheldon this Nobel Prize winner
was once a baby genius in this image we
can totally see how this precocious
kindergartener grew up to be the Sheldon
Cooper we know in love whether you're a
fan of The Big Bang Theory young Sheldon
or a little bit of both you know that
Sheldon has a twin sister Missy and as
it turns out Missy wasn't too saddened
when Sheldon left her behind in the
fourth grade and skipped up to ninth
grade all I know is he's not in the same
grade is me anymore and I'm thrilled
good luck with your finger painting in
this picture of shall we call him very
young Sheldon though the Cooper Twins
were surely still in school together and
probably getting on each other's nerves
how adorable speaking of a adorable
Sheldon's BFF Leonard was also super
cute in his youth at least from the
looks of this picture Leonard hoffstad
who's played by Johnny glei was 27 years
old when we first met him in season 1 of
The Big Bang Theory in this image though
he looks to be only about a year old we
can't get over how happy he looks to be
sitting on the coffee table in his teeny
tiny overalls this future physicist was
already wearing his prescription glasses
and probably solving equations at
daycare okay maybe not that but we have
a feeling he knew what sound a sheep
made at the very least and probably way
earlier than the other kids while we
love imagining him hanging out with his
future pal Sheldon even back in their
baby days this isn't actually Canon
according to the series in the season 3
episode of The Big Bang Theory the
staircase implementation it said that
when Leonard first put in an application
to room with Sheldon that was the first
time the future friends ever actually
met according to the timeline this put
the pair in their early 20s when they
met each other rather than their early
daycare days pretty cute to think about
either way and what's even cuter to
think about that this little baby would
one day marry this little baby yep young
Penny looks exactly like we would have
imagined in this picture though we would
have pictured her wearing something a
little more Penny like pink perhaps
either way we can definitely tell that
this little cutie with her pretty blonde
braids was surely as popular at age
three as she would be in season 1 of The
Big Bang the when she was 21 years old
penny is of course played by the famous
Kaye kuoko and while this is the
youngest we've ever seen Penny many of
us have seen kuoko fairly young too but
may not have realized it kuoko played
Connie Reinhardt in the 1992 TV movie
quicksand No Escape quok was only seven
in this role and yeah we can totally see
this being her a few years earlier as
for Penny she was once an aspiring
actress but back in kindergarten she was
sticking to puppet shows Penny isn't the
only Big Bang Theory leading lady whose
baby counterpart is utterly adorable a
very young Amy Farah Fowler definitely
fits into that category too we all love
Amy Farah Fowler portrayed by mayam biik
and her adorably weird relationship with
Sheldon Cooper they may call her the
female Sheldon one day but looking at
this little lady there's no mistaking
who she grows up to be fans may remember
mayam biic as the titular character in
the popular series Blossom so we already
know a bit about how Amy might have
looked when she was younger biic was 34
when she joined the cast of The Big Bang
Theory but she was only 15 on Blossom
remembering Blossom we can totally
believe that this was her a decade
earlier with a bit of added Amy
personality of course it's hard to
believe that this little one will become
a neuroscientist one day yes this is Dr
Fowler but we can definitely tell that
it's a young Amy the glasses the long
brunette locks the business casual
attire clearly this Super Genius was
already coming into a own at age three
and while she's probably not studying
the human brain as much as she's eating
animal crackers it's safe to say she's
already one smart cookie Howard walowitz
portrayed by Simon hellberg grows up to
be a complicated individual in the early
seasons of The Big Bang Theory he tends
to make people a bit uncomfortable and
he was known to miss some vital social
cues to put it lightly Luckily
everything changes for Howard when he
meets his future wife bernardet sure the
first date this pair went on wasn't the
best puppies where do you stand on
puppies puppy once bit my face of course
it did but it all worked out until I met
you I couldn't imagine spending my life
with just one person and now I can't
imagine spending one day of it without
you while Howard historically might not
be best at First Dates it looks like he
was dressed for one on the first day of
school yep that is definitely him all
right Howard would one day become an
astronaut come on Howard no one's
leaving you up there but in kindergarten
he was dressing up like a full-blown
businessman we're guessing his mom
dressed him real fans know she does have
quite the influence on him after all
speaking of 2-year-olds dressed for a
day at the office little Raj kapali
looks like he's attending the same
school as his pal Howard as an adult Raj
who's played by Kunal nayar is as shy
and sweet as he is smart and it looks
like that all started when he was still
in daycare little Raj is too adorable in
his little shirt and tie and there's no
mistaking that it's him we recognize
that headful of hair and nervous look
anywhere okay it was the early 80s when
bernardet headed to daycare but wow that
hair outfit and pair of glasses just
scream 80s more like an 80s mom If we're
honest but that does check out
considering the fact that bernardet
admitted feeling like she was treated
like a mom to the other kids in her
family while she may look like she's in
a costume baby bernardet is undeniably
cute we all know that bernardet played
by Melissa Rouch didn't have the easiest
childhood feeling like she had to raise
her younger siblings but before she had
to worry about that she was downright
adorable speaking of downright adorable
Stuart Bloom was just a little seedling
starting to bloom in this image the vest
the curls the earnest expression Stuart
played by Kevin susman may be one of the
older members of The Big Bang Theory
friend group but at one time he was the
cutest kid in the whole kindergarten
class by the background we can tell that
while was young Stuart had already
solidified himself as a comic book of
fishon a and we assume that decades
before he became an incredible artist
Bloom started out how we all do with
finger paints is this how you'd picture
The Big Bang Theory in their youth any
questions which one surprised you I
don't understand the question let's talk
about it in the comments and if you love
videos like this one how about that you
were right like And subscribe to the
things for
more